aunque todavía se trata de resultados
preliminares los partidos tradicionales
seguirán manteniendo la mayoría de los
128 escaños del parlamento libanés sin
embargo el descontento social por la
tremenda crisis económica que atraviesa
el país y que ha llevado a más del 80%
de la población libanesa a vivir bajo el
umbral de la pobreza ha abierto una
puerta a los diputados independientes
los libaneses culpan a la élite política
gobernante de haber llevado el país a la
quiebra total y es por eso que aunque la
participación no haya sido más de un 41%
algunos han decidido dar un voto de
castigo a estos partidos tradicionales
que llevan más de 30 años en el poder
votando a candidatos independientes que
quieran luchar contra la corrupción y el
clientelismo político en el sur del país
por ejemplo feudo de hezbollah hubiera
sido impensable en 2018 que ganará un
candidato independiente pero las
manifestaciones masivas de 2019 han
hecho que haya un cambio de mentalidad y
haya muchos libaneses
busquen ese cambio sin embargo el
resultado final no lo darán los votos
que han ganado los candidatos de los
partidos sino las nuevas alianzas que se
formen en el parlamento libanés